Linda Oh McMurray author of the life of
Ida B Wells why did you call us to keep
the waters troubled it came from a quote
that wells made herself she was run out
of Memphis Tennessee because of an
editorial on lynching she did and she
later asserted that the reason that she
was run out is because the Free Press
the paper that she owned was the
disturbing element that kept the waters
troubled and to me it seemed like a
pretty good way to summarize Wells
herself because there were a lot of
exasperated qualities that will had but
she was not somebody that could be
ignored and I think that there is a
definite place for people who will not
allow complacency to develop when did
she live she was born in 1862 in Holly
Springs Mississippi and she ended up
moving from there to Memphis when her
parents both of her parents died in the
yellow fever epidemic and eight 1878 and
so she at sixteen took over her the care
of her siblings and it became head of
the household and she moved to Memphis
in 1881 because it became a better place
to be a teacher when she died
she died in 1931 how old would she been
then I guess about 69 you've got a
picture that's on the cover and I want
to get a real good close-up of this it's
also inside the book what do you see
when you look at that picture well to me
that it wasn't this was made right about
the time that she was at the peak of her
fame and I see I think it shows that
she's a very attractive woman and it
also shows the kind of undercurrent of
sorrow to me too and there was a lot in
her life to be sorry about
well go back to Mississippi where she
was born
what at what age did her both her
parents died she was 16 they both died
then they were they both died in the
yellow fever epidemic how big was the
yellow fever epidemic it was huge that
was a that was the first time that a
yellow fever epidemic had come to as far
as Memphis and so there was not as much
natural immunity that hadn't developed
so it was it was huge
well was thousands of people had what
happened to you when you got yellow
fever well large percentage of people
who got it dying it's what happened how
did you get it through mosquitoes do we
have that problem solved um through
mosquito control and if you go into
places where that yellow fever is
rampant they do get give you an
immunization for it I think but her
check both of her parents died and one
of her siblings dying and the her father
was a Mason and so the Mason showed up
at their house and said we're gonna farm
this child out here and this child out
there and Wells just shook her head said
no my parents would it would it would
just destroy my parents to see the
family split up if you can help me find
work I'll take care of them I make kids
were there she had four younger siblings
that were still alive did she take care
of them yes where she started out in
Holly Springs getting a teaching job out
in the country near there and then in
1881 her aunt invited her to come to
Memphis and at first she wasn't able to
get a job teaching in Memphis
so she was teaching out in Woodstock
which was nearby but the the kids well
the two boys by that time were old
enough to be apprenticed out and to sort
of be on their own and her two younger
sisters came with her to Memphis and
lived with her her aunt she and her aunt
lived together and they lived there but
Wells was the primary support for the
family you know how far is Holly Springs
Mississippi from Memphis not that far
Holly Springs is an extremely
the extreme north of Mississippi and so
it's not a really long trip back and
forth have you been there yes I've been
there is there a place that is there
either be wells home or a museum or
something like that
not much in Memphis they do to have a
historical marker now for her but her
home where she where she eventually live
ended up was in Chicago and for her home
there it has been made a National
Historic Site one of the previous book
notes young fellow was here when he was
18 he's now in college Lee Allen Jones
and in talking about the projects in
Chicago he mentioned the i2b Wells
development let me just run it just a
little 50 40 minute clip about and so we
make a contact there this is the actual
14 story that the 14th row at the 14th
floor and where is this this adapted
deaf homes and Adaro homes
whichever one you may prefer to call it
in the I to be welded up wails that
building actually is being torn down you
think that's a good idea it's it's you
know it's a little bit too late but I'm
glad it's coming down why because Minh
ever really served their purpose they
were put up there and say they were put
up there cheaply first of all and yet
it's it's it's a sad sight I want you to
live in those conditions what do you
think why would they name a whole
project after I to be Wells well she was
always I think perhaps more recognized
in Chicago than elsewhere in the country
so that was really our first major
honour was having this housing complex
named for her I think it was 1940 it was
built or something like that of course
she would have been horrified at what
the style and level of living that
developed out of that complex why well
it is a fine it's been a scene of many
sad occurrences because it has all as he
was saying
it has all the terrible disadvantages of
that high density for a housing project
kind of subsidized housing what had she
done in her life that they would name a
project like that after well one
reviewer of the book said he wished that
I could have put the brakes on well so
that he could have had could have caught
his breath between it it was a lot that
she did she first became well-known or
her first major event actually came two
years after moving to Memphis when she
wrote a trying between Woodstock where
she was teaching and Memphis where she
was living and at that time segregation
had not been firmly established it was
just in the process of being established
and so she always got a ticket and rode
the lady's car and one day they came and
told her to move from the ladies car and
she refused and so they he reached over
to grab her and throw her off the train
and she bit him they didn't get as much
publicity it does illustrate her
temperament however but what happened
after down is not only did she refuse to
leave the train willingly but she sued
the railroad coming and won initially it
was eventually overturned on appeal but
she won and that got a lot of publicity
and the black press and it actually
launched her career into journalism
because she began to write articles
about her suit and then that launched
into writing articles on all kinds of
things to the various black newspapers
of the time and many of them had
national
readership and so she assumed the name
iolo and became pretty well known as a
white journalist I although Welles as
that was it know her her name she just
used the violet period she didn't use
her full name may have been because she
was a little bit concerned about the
impact it might have on her teaching
career if it was wild known
widespread knowledge of who was writing
these editorials and but she never did
check her pin for anybody she eventually
did get fired from teaching because she
criticized the school board for some of
its actions and a newspaper
go back to the Train what were the
different classes at that time in the
south you say the lady's car and and why
would she have why would they have asked
her to leave well to a large extent the
designation of lady's cars was a
contradiction to what the image that
White's wanted other White's to have of
black women beginning in slavery black
women had been sexually exploited and
with impunity and in the classic
argument of the racist out of the rapist
I mean they they said you know she
really wanted it so a picture of black
women as being particularly sensual and
depraved emerged and so consequently at
the end of slavery it was a very
important priority for black women to
get the respect they had never had and
it also was a high priority among
southern white races to see that she
didn't get the designation of lighting
so it was a big deal to black women to
be forced to leave the ladies car and go
to the smoking cars where they normally
were sent and they were Cynthia and the
smoking car became the jump-rope car the
segregated car and in the South in those
years and what years are we talking
about now in Memphis um in the 1880s
what was the population base how big was
Memphis what was the ratio black and
white you know I really don't recall
exactly it was Memphis was a relatively
new city and it had been wiped out by
the yellow fever epidemic too and so to
some extent it really had begun over in
1878
was not nearly the size it is today but
it was still it was a very rapidly
growing city and african-americans made
up a sizable minority of the residents
in Memphis when did the Beale Street the
jazz and all that come to Memphis um it
it was developing my Wells was there
Bill Street was a long street and and
the part that most Americans are
familiar with are where all the Blues
clubs and things like that were there's
another part of Gill Street that was
kind of the black Wall Street of Memphis
where white professionals had their
offices and all and that's something I
think a lot of people who read this book
would be surprised as the extent to
which the black elite had developed into
professionals there were a lot of black
doctors and lawyers in Memphis there was
quite a black elite as a matter of fact
probably the wealthiest man in Memphis
was black man by name of Robert Church
you tucked in here about a senator a
black senator I can't I can't find the
name right quickly but and and I
remember you saying that he was the last
black senator up until the 1964 Voting
Rights Act this was back in the 1800s
and he I think he left the house it was
Congress rather than the Senate but no
George white was from North Carolina and
was elected and served till 1901 and
then once he left there were no other
african-americans from the south elected
until after the Voting Rights Act in
1964 sounds like you have a little bit
of a southern accent where are you from
I was born in Montgomery but that was
only because women went home to have
their babies at that time I grew up in
Atlanta and where are you now full-time
I'm a professor at North Carolina State
University where's that nothing Raleigh
North Carolina and what's the population
of the North Carolina State what kind of
school is it um we have about close to
30,000 students it's one of the two
major research universities of the
University of North Carolina
system most people are more aware of our
sister and Chapel Hill but we're both
part of the two designated research
institutions in there we are more
engineering and technical stuff how did
you talk Axford press into doing a book
on how to be wells well actually I
didn't
an agent did but I had already published
a book with Oxford a biography of George
Washington Carver so that I don't think
it was too much of a hard sell it had
done very well and what was that all
about what who was George Washington
Carver he was probably one of the
best-known African Americans in the
1940s 50s and so forth he was a
agricultural scientist at Tuskegee
Institute and became really well known
as a as a black scientist and how did
you get your interest in this well I
went to school I got my PhD at Auburn
University which was 25 miles away from
Tuskegee and that's where all these
papers were which is one reason nobody
had done a full-scale biography of them
I think is that Tuskegee was kind of
inaccessible for most researchers what
it's just she's kind of remote I mean
it's not one of those places they sit
and corporate papers were very expensive
extensive I mean there's something like
it was a whole wall of document boxes
because he did he saved every letter he
ever wrote that's what and or gone
and what did when did he live um he was
born in 1865 and died in 1943 did they
know each other not personally I don't
I'm almost sure they didn't but someone
that she didn't know was Booker T
Washington and and where was he from and
he was the president of Tuskegee
Institute where Carver was working and
he was also known as the kind of
accommodationist spokesperson
for african-americans he he essentially
told African Americans to work hard and
to make themselves respectable and
acceptable to whites and economically
important whites and that their rights
would automatically come to them if they
did that and what did I - well say to
him about that well it completely
contradicted her own experience although
it was very consistent with his
experience what I think was a turning
point for her on this whole issue of
winning rights by respectability was a
lynching of three of her friends in
Memphis which also was a key factor in
the change of the course of her career
these three individuals including
included Thomas miles who she was close
enough to to actually be the godchild of
his of his child and they were lynched
primarily because they opened up a
supermarket in competition with a white
supermarket and so these were young men
who were very respectable they worked
hard they were making themselves
economically important and independent
and they were lynched because they were
successful and so that caused her to
turn a considerable anger towards the
anti lynching violence who's this in
this picture that is a picture of wells
standing up with Tom Moss's wife and two
children and abuse was one of them that
was lynched go back to the lynching
story yeah what year was this it was
1892 she would have been in her 30s when
she was 62 32 yeah no was 18 yet was
1892 she would have been 30 years old
and what were the circumstances um
as I explained but anywhere was the
grocery it was right and it was in an
area that was kind of a fringe between
white and black sections and there was a
single white grocery store there
and boss was the president of this
company that was kind of a cooperative
grocery store the people's store that
opened up it was in direct competition
with the grocery story that was there
and there was bad blood between them all
mom I mean the white owner wanted to run
them out and because they were actually
winning the Battle of competition the
boss was so influential in the black
community he drew a most of the blank
business and even some of the white
business so he was kept trying to find
ways of running him out and then they
had an altercation and he convinced a
judge that Mouse was a danger and so
they had been informed that a white mom
was going to attack the store and
instead there was a group of Deputies
who came that were dressed in civilian
clothes and they thought it was the mom
and so when there it was an exchange of
gunfire and it was blown into a
conspiracy supposedly of a black
insurrection and so they arrested about
30 people but the only people they
lynched were those people who were
directly tied to the store she'd like me
three black men miss Mars
Calvin McDowell and Lee Stewart right
and Thomas Moss wasn't even at the store
when it happened
but he was Lana shhhht anyone then what
happened well Welles happened to be out
of town at the time and which came back
immediately caused her to focus her
attention on the issue of lynching and
in the course of doing this she began to
refute the myths that had been
perpetrated to justify lynching my white
moms
that was that white men were essentially
so beastial that they had to have the
restraining hand of you know the white
mom to keep them under control and so
right was given us the major reason for
lynching and even people who disagreed
with lynching essentially believed that
you know rape was the cause well with
this lynching of these three people she
knew that it was not right wasn't any
way involved and so she began
investigating and began to discover that
rape wasn't even in charge in the vast
majority of lynchings and in this
particular one and even when it was
charged it could be something like of
like me I'm winking at a woman would be
attempted rape or something like that so
she began to challenge that and she
wrote an editorial in the Memphis free
speech but what she was editor at that
time by that time and essentially
implied that this cry of rape was could
be a source of embarrassment for white
women because that most of released many
white women were willing participants
and sexual liaisons with black men and
didn't raise the ripe until afterwards
well needless to say her editorial
infuriated white Memphis and she was out
of town then and they came to the
offices of the Free Press and ran her
partner out of town and eventually all
of the presses and so forth were
confiscated and she was told by people
from Memphis that she should not come
back they didn't have free press and
Memphis then oh that was the name of her
news no no but I mean they didn't owe it
no it doesn't that that was the end of
the Free Press you couldn't go to court
and no um african-americans had very
little legal protection during that
period of time what impact did the
reconstruction have on Memphis in that
part of the country
well I'm not sure exactly what you mean
well you know at the Civil War and then
he had the Reconstruction period and
were the blacks involved at all in any
of the governing of the city yeah there
were there was a good deal of black
involvement early on was there any
occupation the true parking yeah well
Memphis became kind of a headquarters
for the northern troops and so during
the war and large numbers of slaves and
free blacks would would run to Memphis
to get behind them the army lines so
there was a conceal of friction there
and getting a deal of an opportunity for
blacks as well when you went to find her
story how hidden was it I know she did
an autobiography um well it was to me it
was much too hidden although recent
scholarships beginning to recognize
their importance she should have had a
full scale biography years earlier she
had her autobiography which his daughter
tried to get published and was not able
to get published until 1970 she also had
wrote some Diaries while she was in
Memphis which were a wonderful source
for her ideas and her personality and so
forth although good portion of the diary
was about her romantic affairs and
things of that sort it still gave a lot
of unsigned and where'd you find the
Diaries the diaries were at the
University of Chicago where all of her
papers are her papers were very limited
though because I I understand there was
a house fire or something like that and
so they don't have that many papers but
one of the sources I got a lot of
information from with the various black
newspapers and where did you find them
many of them have been microfilmed
and so we could get them through
microfilm and how long did this fire if
you take you well let's see I started
thinking about wells about problem
the 1991 and actively began working on
the biography in 93 and it came out in
98 and you say that the 90 1892 was when
the Memphis lunching occurred and then
there's this you have this in your book
about the lectures that she used to give
and that she was called in New York some
way and that began her career as a
lecturer yes she when she was
essentially run out of Memphis what
happened is that she moved to New York
where she became affiliated with the New
York age which was a leading black
newspaper and the fact that she was in
exile added to the interest of her story
and so forth so that she began to give
lectures and that was one of the
lectures that she gave that the brochure
let me just look at this closely it says
miss Ida B Wells a lecturer Metropolitan
AME Church Monday evening October 31st
1892 and it says talks about southern
Maude rule and will be introduced by T
Thomas fortune who was he he was the
editor of the Free State Attorney New
York age that she went to work for and
what was he like and what role he play
in her life well he became a mentor
early on in her course of journalism and
so forth T Thomas fortune also was the
founder of the afro-american council and
Wells was involved in the founding of
that organization as well as just about
every major organization that had to do
with black rights she was involved in
the founding of the gun double ACP the
National Association of colored women
did I agree movement she was the
probably the most active woman in that
that was WWE Dubois is great and oh
you've got this photograph for this full
page of photographs and mr. fortune is
up there in the left hand corner and
then you have Booker T Washington off to
the right Frederick Douglass in the
middle and I
be Wells down there on the right who's
down the left-hand gray yeah that's I
garland pin he was had just currently
written a book about blank journalist
what is this we're looking at it came
from a book of the period I think it was
called the college for life or something
like that it was kind of a celebration
of black life and culture and what I
think was important about this
photograph is that it Illustrated this
was in 1895 it was sort of Douglass was
considered the outstanding leader and
spokesperson and so he's in the middle
but it's almost like these are
satellites around him are the contenders
for his mantle because he was aging at
the time and I thought it was very
significant that Welles was one of them
and duggie divorce was not but he was
not very well known in 1895 what was I
to be Welles this relationship with
Frederick Douglass three-plus he very
much supported anti-lynching campaign
and wrote a preface for her first anti
lynching pamphlet that grew out of her
lectures and newspaper articles about
lynching she also went to his house a
number of times and she he especially
appreciated her because she accepted his
wife his second wife after his first
wife died Douglass married a white woman
and many people were upset about it but
Douglass wrote her and said that she
always gave his wife the you know the
kind of respect that she deserved
there's another lynching incident a
fellow named Sam hoes what was that um
so many lynching she was involved is
known in Georgia you and in Georgia
well that was one that it occurred down
there and it was it was a pretty
terrible lynching but it was also a
lynching that occurred down in Booker T
Washington's neck of the woods and by
eventually the role of leadership from
that
of Douglas we were going to be filled by
Booker T Washington W invoice as kind of
contenders for the throne and he was
somewhat apologetic about the hoes
lynching which infuriated Wells but it
was impossible for Wells to accept
Booker T Washington's philosophy later
on she had support him early on because
as I say their ideas were totally
contradictory he was saying that
respectability would bring rights and
she was saying that you know
respectability is what caused many and
much lynching white progress rather than
regression is what caused lynching who
is this that's Fred Ferdinand Barnett
she finally found her soul mate when she
met him after she moved to Chicago he
was a lawyer and activist also and owned
a newspaper in Chicago the Chicago
conservator earlier she'd had problems
with men because any man that was strong
enough for her to respect she was afraid
she would lose her independence if she
could you know became too closely
involved or especially got married she
didn't really want to get married but
foreign Ferdinand Barnett was
exceptional how old was she when she got
married oh she was 33 I believe it was
and how many children did she have um
she had four she also had two stepsons
that were grown by the time her own
family
are these all her kids right here those
are all four kids right there there are
two stepsons that were probably in their
late teens when that picture was made
and are any of these kids alive um
granddaughters or not none of them or
else are still alive but there are some
grandchildren around yes what were her
kids like and how did that work out and
they were they were very different the
best source of information on the wealth
of our net family is probably the
daughter that was instrumental in
getting her
autobiography published that's the whole
family here yes I think that's got them
all pictures in 1970 mm-hmm yeah that
was that's the family including grandson
the early grandchildren - and how did
item B Wells and her husband work
together it was an unconventional
marriage for that time and certainly for
- maybe today they were temperamentally
opposite barnett was very easygoing and
there was nothing easygoing about Wells
borne out she took the wells burn out
she did don't take his name
she hyphenated her name but he was
supportive of her
he was as militant as she was and
supportive he actually hired a
housekeeper to do the housework and he
did most of the cooking because he liked
to and he would hire nursemaids to go
with her when she could she could
continue her lectures and activities and
so forth say there were Republicans yes
most African Americans at that time were
Republicans what did that mean well the
Republican Party was still identified as
the party of emancipation and the
Republican Party really was more
supportive of black rights than the
Democratic Party for most of that period
of time it begins to shift with a new
deal and Roosevelt's election what were
the Ida be wells club or is it a club or
clubs they have different oh yeah well
there were clubs that formed even before
she came to Chicago even before she
became as famous as she was she was
inspiring the formation of some clubs
the one in Chicago's began soon after
she got there and continued to be one of
the groups through which she worked
when did she go to England and why um
she'd made two tours to England and a a
93 and 94 18 1893 and 1894 yes there was
a woman who was over in the United
States touring a name her name was
Katherine MP and she was became alarmed
about lynching and she also met Wells
and she's figured that she'd be very
effective to bring to England to Ryles
the English cinnamon against lynching
and so she and another woman in Britain
in Gregory and I think is the bill on
mayo was and it was in Scotland I'm not
sure but any rate they brought her over
for a tour and then brought Katherine
Thiebaud her no mayo brought her back
for a second tour in 94 well you know
part of what you wrote about the English
becoming sympathetic toward what Wells
crusade was about but during the civil
war would the British somewhat
sympathetic to the south the white South
the leadership was at least and
economically because of the dependence
of pen cotton but a large portion of the
people in general were anti-slavery
largely through the work of Frederick
Douglass who went over on British tours
like wells did later were there any
people of color in Great Britain in that
time very limited number so what would
the pitch be when she would go over
there what was the purpose the purpose
was to play the role that favorite
Douglass at play that is to rouse
British public opinion so that they
would it would embarrass the young
people in the United States to do
something about it
did it work yes I mean in a sense of
getting White's attention it definitely
did she she began to be very highly
criticized in the white for us
for her efforts when was this taken do
you know and what was she doing at this
period that was in 1917 and the little
button on her collar there is says
something like iron martyred Negro
soldiers it was after a shootout in
Houston between black troops and white
citizens and without a trial many of
these black soldiers were executed and
so she was essentially raising hell
about that and it led to an interesting
visit by the military intelligence of
the secret services some agents like
that that came to her house and told her
that she could be arrested for sedition
if she did that decease in the US and
she essentially told him well if if I'm
gonna be the one I I'm not gonna stop
what I'm doing if you put me in jail all
right because I would rather be sitting
in jail than not speak up about the
truth but of course they didn't arrest
her she was 55 at the time and a mother
of four and so they they did not arrest
her and but she it does illustrate that
she never backed down and she didn't
care who she was talking to she was
gonna tell the truth as she saw it was
she religious yes very religious which
religion well she kind of moved around
but she was Church of Christ while she
was in Memphis which made sense because
she was kind of a free thinker anyway
and the Church of Christ was one of a
denomination that tried to be ecumenical
and it's Christianity sort of thing sort
of so that she was to when she was in
Memphis she went to about a dozen
different churches but she was a member
of the Church of Christ you have here in
the book page 339 I'm getting three
lessons
in life I don't know if you remember
this part of not but her list of three
began with the success of a local papers
campaign urging people not to shop where
they could not work what was the point
ah well I by the way these are licensed
from from one the year passed she was
this was a New Year's thing where she
was writing about the lessons and that
would have been in 1930 it was a boycott
against merchants who would not hire
African Americans and essentially saying
that you should not shop there if you
cannot work there the second on this was
she called us the bloodless battle for
recognition of progress in the economic
field the second lesson was learned when
lobbying efforts prevented the
confirmation of John Jay Parker a
southern segregationist to the Supreme
Court this victory taught quote the
strength of our political Worth did they
stop this man from being largely the
work of the n-double a-c-p but it might
be n double acp and wells often
duplicated efforts she eventually had a
falling out with the leadership at the
n-double-a-cp or at least the black
finger ship with the n-double-a-cp what
was the reason for the fall well she and
the boys became kind of it to
loggerheads and Du Bois was the
highest-ranking black number of
n-double-a-cp in the early stage is the
only one on the board
was it a General Counsel no he was
director of research and the publisher
of the crisis which was the publication
of the n-double a-c-p the third lesson
for that year and she died the next year
crying remember wells Burnett praised
pastures now I mean praise the
critically acclaimed performance of
black actors in the play green pastures
which she called a wonderful testimonial
to Negro art and religion wells Barnett
visited presidents and scolded
newspapers for using the term [ __ ] yeah
that's it that's a very good quote let
me see I have some quotes marked in here
that
okay here it is she that she wrote to a
letter to the editor of a Chicago paper
and they were calling this retired or
this this man who had died or something
they were talking about
I think they referred team as a old
Negro news boy or in an aged [ __ ] and
she protested the use of that
terminology and she closed the letter
with a quote that I think is very
significant that this may seem a small
matter to a large number of readers but
it is part of the great whole and after
all there is only a difference in degree
between taking a man's self-respect and
taking his life nothing was too big or
too small for Wells to tackle she's best
known for anti lynching efforts but she
was a strong lobbyist in Illinois and
was responsible or Parton campaigns to
turn back every attempt to segregate the
schools and Chicago that's why getting
back to your earlier question about the
housing project
she also established a black settlement
house settlement house kind of in
Chicago she established the first black
women's suffrage group in Illinois she
was very active in the fight for women's
rights as well as for black rights but
she always put raised concerns over
gender concerns Marcus Garvey's
mentioned in your book yes where did he
come into the picture who was he where
is he from he was from Jamaica and he
became a challenge to Dubois his
leadership because he formed the United
Negro Improvement Association I mean he
was living in Harlem at the time and he
was recruiting a large numbers of
essentially lower-class African
Americans into this organization which
was a black nationalist kind of
organization that
rejected essentially any kind of racial
intermixing and you say that he
eventually was convicted on mail fraud
in 1924 what happened to him then he was
- he served about two years in prison
and then was deported back to Jamaica
but he actually moved to London after
that he was a separatist right did she
believe in separatism one of the things
that I think is significant about Wells
at this book I hope captures is that
most of the labels are far too
simplistic she blurts she did believe in
self-help with Booker T Washington some
wise but she didn't believe in this
accommodation she believed in
secretin in some ways but she remained a
committed integrationist there were a
lot of ambivalent feelings among much of
the black elite about what were the
appropriate tactics and so forth and she
essentially I think was for anything
that worked when she spoke was it to
black audiences or white audiences um
both an England of course it was white
audiences but she also spoke to white
audiences in Boston and other places -
you paint a picture in here from time to
time of someone who was argumentative
angry didn't get along with some people
I mean how give us that scenario I mean
Oh what was she what do you think she
didn't like to know exasperated why well
because she never compromised she was
till the day she died she was
uncompromising and it made many people
uncomfortable because it made males seem
timid who's this in the picture her
husband that's her husband and that's
alfredo duster her daughter she was
Alfredo Barnett at the time but who
later was responsible for
getting autobiography published and also
did a wonderful interview that's
available that is the best source on the
Barnett family life I think have you
ever heard her voice no I haven't is it
anywhere to be heard it may be I don't
know I mean did you ever have it did you
ever read a characterization of how she
would speak oh yes afraid to duster for
a minute
no I don't think there is any existing
tape there were a lot of people who
described her style of speaking which
was constrained but impassioned she was
it she have a difficult position as a
lecturer because at that point in time
in the 18 at least before the 20th
century it was kind of risky for women
to speak out in public period they
tended to get criticized for that but
she was not only speaking out in public
she was speaking out about sexually
explicit matters like right and so she
felt like she had to maintain a very
ladylike demeanor and she usually used
white newspapers and so forth to make
her points so that she was she was
quoting from the enemy kind of thing but
apparently she was very dynamic speaker
go back to the beginning and her parents
say that she lost him both aged 16
yellow fever where do you think she got
this spirit that she had well I think
somewhat some fun degree of temperament
is inherited you know I think
genetically some people are more
combative
but I think there were a lot of factors
that played into her temperament she was
the oldest child and especially after
her parents death she had to
really become as she's listed in the
sentences that's a head of household she
was angry because both of the gender
roles she was expected to play which she
didn't really consciously admit to
herself but she bought two that she also
was angry at the treatment that
african-americans gone
she really was just uncompromisingly
militant you have here in the beginning
a dedication uh-huh and the dedication
says to Alan W Jones who made a
historian out of a housewife and the
John a Edwards who has bought that
historic historian much brought that
historian much happiness who are these
two people Alan W Jones was my major
professor when I was at Auburn and a
wonderful mentor and responsible for me
to becoming a historian he actually ran
into me in a grocery store and got me
undergraduate schedule and John Edwards
is my husband go back to the first part
of this that made a historian out of a
housewife what were you doing and what
year was this um I uh I started graduate
school in 1971 and I was what had you
been doing I've been working as a
customer service representative at a
manufacturing plant and near Auburn and
I just happened to run to it end to him
in the grocery store and he this was
actually earlier than 71 and what I
really wanted to do is get pregnant and
so he finally got me to apply for
graduate school and I got my acceptance
and a positive pregnancy test the same
week and so I stayed home for a while
with my daughter but he kept calling a
very few months saying are you ready to
put that mind to use he finally
convinced me to go to graduate school
and where'd you go at Tobin University
and what did you get appears to pitch to
you in what in history I majored in
my major field was recent American
history but most of my research and most
of my emphasis was in african-american
history how did he know that you'd be a
good candidate for PhD well I had I come
back I had been to Auburn for the last
two years of my college I went to Emory
first two years and over in the second
two years and so I had been away and
then came back and to finish my work at
Auburn and I had him as a professor that
my last semester at all
this is he still are yes he is and as he
read your books yes he has he was very
instrumental in the first two because
they did a biography of Munro work so
almost nobody knows about but that was
my master's thesis expanded and then my
biography of Carver was my dissertation
expanded and of course he was there at
the inception of both of those even
after I graduated he would call me or
write me and say they're having a
conference on such as us here you ought
to go give a paper oh I'm Carver and
things like that so he continued to
mentor me even after I got my degree
what reaction do you get from African
Americans a white woman writing about
black people mixed but for the most part
I think fairly supportive I know John
Hope Franklin essentially told me
directly he said you know don't don't
worry about anybody who thinks she
shouldn't be writing about black
subjects he said you ought to be judged
on the merit of your workmen on the
clear skin is he down there and in there
yes we're all part of what they call
Research Triangle Chapel Hill Durham and
Raleigh are all in a very closed radius
and he's a dude named he was at
University of Chicago for a long time
and John a Edwards your husband where'd
you meet him in Raleigh how long you've
been married
um two years just two years yeah I think
about - yeah about two years what's he
do he's an engineer oh he retired
and what does he think of all this
attention to history and biography he's
he's very supportive too I mean he
should you say here who brought that
historian much happiness that is quite
true
who was Monroe Nathan work that you
wrote about he was a black sociologist
and the significance of him was that he
actually joined Du Bois as Niagara
movement which was an anti Booker T
Washington movement but then that was in
1905 but in 1908 he accepted a job at
Tuskegee and moved over to the
Washington camp so he was actually had a
the only person had a foot in both camps
that became the mating major two
divisions of power and tactics for
african-americans at the time he also
was very interested in Africa well
before most African Americans were when
you look back on Ida B wells his life
what worked what moved people to do
things and did you get any any analysis
from her about what she thought really
mattered to speaking the writing the
marching all that her writing probably
was it was the thing that was most
effective because you know she could
only give a limited number of speeches
but there was certainly she published
numbers of pamphlets as well as
newspaper articles and so forth but her
speaking was very important as well
did she make money from speaking no no
they sometimes paid her expenses or
something of that sort but she didn't
really actually make her money that went
well she and her husband financially
sound um yes but they could have been a
lot better off her husband was a lawyer
who tended to specialize in the rights
of of defendants and so forth and so he
often took cases pro bono and actually
even would pay the clients way of Cour
and everything else and they even
brought some of his clients into the
house to live with him so they gave away
a lot of what they had but he was he had
a certain amount of financial security
because he was successful in law as a
matter of fact he became a deputy said
to state attorney and one time and in
the end you say shilling to be 69 yes
what did she die oh um I think it was an
arraignment poisoning or something it's
what the yeah designation was was it
quick or do you know it's really quick
I'm shoot she's been deteriorating but
just a year before she ran for the state
Senate and lost but so she she was
active up for the practically today she
died will you suggest that she only got
something like 583 vultures did she
actually think she could win oh I think
one of the things that was significant
about her is she felt that there were
battles worthy to be fought even if he
couldn't win them and took sin today
that's what she did on her life she
fought battles over everything that
regarded black rights and all so much in
the area of women's suffrage compared to
your biography of George Washington
Carver was this harder or easier
different Carver the sources were
overwhelming because of its personal
papers being so extensive and so forth
and he was much better known so that it
took a lot more work to piece the story
out even though she has her
autobiography of course that only tells
one sign and that kind of it's really
reads more like a legal brief for her
against all our critics you know so that
finding the real her and finding
information the biographies that were
coming the diaries were great too but it
still was much more difficult to pin
down the information so they were coming
from office of what the ends of the
extreme as far as research were
concerned
do you have another book that you're
gonna do well I got several kind of
working in the back of my mind
the thing that I've launched into right
now or beginning is a study a
comparative study of black leadership
and the post-emancipation period
throughout British America I've just
become very fascinated this is my
favorite time period for research is the
reconstruction and post reconstruction
period and I've become so concerned so
interested in black leadership during
that period in the United States and the
various forms and nature's of it and I
also love the Bahamas we have a boat and
take it down there quite frequently and
so I started trying to figure out some
way I could time these two loves
together and so I decided I started to
do something about blacks on the Bahamas
but I decided that it probably would be
more interesting to do a comparative
leadership approach have any opinion on
her the best leader was from that period
um you mean the Washington Dubois
Douglas best leader um well I think
Dubois ended up being the most effective
whether you you consider it best or not
he was the most effective here's the
book it's a biography of I to be wells
by Linda Olmec Marie we thank you very
much for joining us thank you